okay it's happening I was not going to
stream today but we have gigantic just
enormous breaking news which is that
Donald Trump plans to in signing the
recent budget deal that gives him no
money for the wall but a little bit of
money for some bollards on 55 miles of
fencing he is going to sign it to avert
a government shutdown which would have
started I believe it's tomorrow night at
midnight but he is also going to declare
a national emergency in order to justify
commandeering the money that he wants to
build the wall this is massive massive
news we have to consider multiple
elements here we have to consider the
legality of this we have to consider
what happens next and the court battles
that are going to start the political
consequences and always in the back is
the use of these decisions to distract I
was thinking of what more nuanced word
but really it's to distract from the
closing circle of criminality around
Donald Trump the latest of which is of
course the news from today that the plea
agreement for his campaign chairman Paul
Manafort has been voided because of his
persistent lying even after signing that
prosecution agreements so we're going to
be going through a whole bunch of stuff
here and I'm really glad that you're
with me I plan to stream for a while I
will open the phone lines as I often do
during the streams if people want me to
if we get ten new patrons members or
YouTube channel members information
about that in the description this is a
live stream so we can actually have a
back-and-forth about what's going on if
you have questions for me if you have
comments you want me to read and react
to please use the dollar symbol at the
bottom of the chat window also known as
super chat we will put those up on the
screen and I will address them and talk
about them and if you have questions
that's all great sign up for membership
on our website couple of coupon codes
available in the description I'll say
more about that later don't troll the
chat a lot of people got banned
yesterday during during the stream
unfortunately because of troll
and you can become a YouTube channel
member using the join button down below
so let's get right into it first and
foremost we have an article from the New
York Times explaining what's going on
let's take a look President Trump plans
to declare a national emergency so he
can bypass Congress and build his
long-promised wall along the border even
as he signs a spending bill that does
not fund it the White House said
Thursday this was originally mentioned
by Mitch McConnell and then immediately
confirmed by the White House that yes
this is the plan the announcement of his
decision came minutes before the Senate
voted 83 to 16 to advance the spending
package in anticipation of final passage
on Thursday night by the house so here's
what happened folks it became clear that
Republicans overwhelmingly were of the
mindset of we've got to pass this bill
we can't have another government
shutdown the last one was an absolute
and total disaster for us so Trump
realized or someone told him as is often
the case that he's going to have a real
problem politically if both Democrats
and Republicans are completely on board
in the House and Senate with a bill that
would reopen the government with no real
wall funding it gives him this billion
bucks for bollards on 55 miles I mean 55
miles is nothing right that he is going
to suffer politically if he shuts down
the government again when both Democrats
and Republicans are united about the
fact that they need to avert another
government shutdown so the idea here is
okay if I have to agree to this bill the
spending bill that doesn't give me money
for the wall what else can I do
and the answer of course is declare a
national emergency and try to commandeer
the funding for the wall that's not
going to be quite so easy and we'll get
to that momentarily mr. Trump's decision
to sign it effectively ends a two-month
war of attrition between the President
and Congress that as we know led to a 35
day government shutdown and facing
another one it could instigate a new
constitutional clash over who controls
the federal purse
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
President Trump will sign the government
funding bill as he has stated before he
will also take other executive action
including a national emergency
to ensure we stop the national security
and humanitarian crisis at the border
Speaker Nancy Pelosi
says Democrats are reviewing our options
to respond to that declaration didn't
rule out a legal challenge the president
is doing an end run around Congress she
raised the possibility that Trump was
setting precedent for Democratic
presidents to come precisely what
Republicans fear you want to talk about
a national emergency let's talk about
today reminding mr. Trump about the
anniversary of the Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School shooting that's a
national emergency why don't you clear
that and declare that emergency mr.
president I wish you would okay so and
then this is a key propaganda moment the
president is once again delivering on
his promise to build the wall protect
the border and secure our great country
so here's what we have to say I'm in
this is this is a mess this is truly a
mess that we are experiencing right now
number one the idea first we have to
look at is the wall going to be built
even if Donald Trump declares a national
emergency and it is legally upheld that
by doing that he will be allowed to
commandeer money to build a wall across
the entire us-mexico border that's the
most optimistic scenario for Trump okay
give him everything he gets to take
money for the wall number one where does
that money come from that's that's the
first question because it's got to come
out of somewhere else and it very likely
is going to be from places that most
Republicans aren't going to be pleased
with all right that's number one
that's going to be a real question
number two if construction on a wall
across the entire us-mexico border
started today it is unlikely to be
finished by the end of Donald Trump's
presidency even if he gets reelected
engineers have looked at the wall every
single one of the prototypes that was
proposed for the wall where they did I
don't remember if it was like 20 feet a
bunch of different vendors did like 20
feet of how they would build the wall
and they submitted buried
general estimates of what it would cost
to do here's the problem with those
estimates I won't redo this entire thing
because we have a lot to get to and I
did an entire segment on this number one
the prototypes were done nowhere near
where the wall would actually be built
in terms of terrain so whatever cost
there was 420 feet multiplied by what is
it twelve twelve hundred miles I don't
even remember how many miles at his
total of border doesn't account for the
fact that to actually build the wall
across the entire us-mexico border you
need to get both equipment and people to
those places none of that is accounted
for in the cost of a 20 foot wide
prototype that's number one number two
the costs that are being cited from
those estimates are now two years old
all of that stuff costs more partially
because of Donald Trump's own tariffs
and lastly it would take years there are
engineers who estimate it could be a
decade to build the entire thing by that
point pieces of the wall that are built
first would already require maintenance
none of that is priced in okay so the
the wall as it was originally conceived
is a fantasy but let's get into the
national emergency declaration this is
so early that we still don't know the
legality of declaring a national
emergency to build a wall on the
southern border will discuss crisis in a
moment okay but let's take a step back
from that and take this one piece at a
time
as I like to do in order to actually
let's imagine that there is going to be
a court challenge to this you are going
to need to demonstrate that there is
actually a crisis right because if you
are going to say we need to declare a
national emergency which is normally
done for very different things which
I'll get to momentarily the Trump
administration should and we're trying
to figure out what legally is going to
be required should have to prove that we
have a crisis or national emergency how
do you do that with immigration when
number one illegal border crossings have
been declining for a decade okay
numbered so right away if it's a crisis
now it was a bigger crisis two years
why didn't Trump declare the national
emergency then why wasn't he trying to
get the money for the wall that doesn't
make any sense
number two net outflow of immigrants to
Mexico rather than coming in from Mexico
number three drugs most coming through
ports of entry the wall wouldn't do a
damn thing about it
number four criminality undocumented
immigrants and documented immigrants
both commit crime in the United States
at lower rates than american-born
citizens why it's obvious why if you
know you're here illegally or you know
that you're an immigrant even though
you're legal you were still seen as an
outsider in many communities you are not
going to do anything that will get you
on the radar of law enforcement which
risks getting you deported okay obvious
so if indeed the Trump administration
will have to prove in court that this
situation warrants a national emergency
by virtue of being a crisis I don't know
how you actually do it and that is
increasingly what early comments from
legal scholars are suggesting which is
that if the donald trump administration
has to prove in court that this is a
crisis they would be unable to do so in
a way that any sensible judge would be
convinced by is probably the the best
way to say it so nothing about this
makes sense and what i want to go to
next and i see that there are super
chats coming in and i see that there are
new members signing up it seems people
do want me to open up the phone lines
which i'm glad to do let's first deal
with the the casual nature with which
this national emergency is being
declared let's see if I can zoom this in
a little bit get us a better view Fred
this is from The Associated Press
President Donald Trump's plan to declare
a national emergency to free up money
for his border wall would be an
extraordinary step despite a statement
that predecessors liberally used such
power
it's a contentious move likely to be
legally challenged and not something
presidents routinely do contrary to his
rhetoric Trump said you know we already
have national emergencies out there you
know President Obama President Clinton
President Bush they've declared many
national
this is not unique they've declared many
national emergencies emergencies many
many soon as Trump uses that phraseology
you know he doesn't know what he's
talking about the facts the emergency
action would be rare the presidency
sites did not use emergency powers to
pay for projects that Congress wouldn't
support no in fact it's usually the
opposite in fact national emergencies
are typically declared in order to fund
priorities that have bipartisan support
in many cases and would pass Congress
but because of the emergency status this
is a quicker way to get that money
so let's actually look at that I happen
to have here a list of national
emergencies in the United States from
Wikipedia each source of course see if I
can get the zoom reasonable for all of
us maybe here is good as of February 20
1958 emergencies have been declared and
31 are still in effect having been
renewed each year by the president let's
just skip all the way down to Barack
Obama to see what's there November 22nd
2015
see I apologize the end is off of it off
the screen but I'll tell you what it
says imposed sanctions on for Burundi
Nationals Minister of Public Security
Alain Guillaume Boone yoni National
Police of Burundi deputy director and
surreal diary and Q key a in the wake of
widespread unrest ok bipartisan support
Obama April 1 2015
intended to allow sanctions to be
leveled on foreign individuals
determined by the Department of the
Treasury to have engaged in cyber crime
or cyber terrorism was in the works for
two years let's look at Obama April 3
2014 enabled economic sanctions to be
placed due to the civil war in South
Sudan sanctions first imposed a month
later let's look at George W Bush June
16 2006 imposed sanctions including a
travel ban on Alexander Lukashenko after
Belarus
crackdown on peaceful protests against
the recent presidential election and
following similar sanctions by the
European Union a multi-country
multinational effort the idea that
because national emergencies exist and
there's this long list here that I'm
scrolling through it's no big deal to
declare one to pay for a pet project
like the wall of course influenced by
number one the growing panic because
Trump has so failed on this issue he was
never going to get Mexico to pay for it
now he's not even able to get Congress
to pay for it so this is what he is now
doing the idea that it makes sense in
that situation to do what was done by
Clinton or Obama or george w bush or
whoever is laughable and ultimately it
may be a court that decides now anytime
we're talking about courts deciding when
it's Donald Trump's presidency we have
to think back to the people small
minority but there were people on the
Left who said I don't care about the
Supreme Court I don't see any real
difference between Trump and Hillary or
Hillary I just don't like so I'm not
going to vote or I'm voting third party
or whatever this may ultimately be
decided by the supreme court and this
makes the obvious importance of the
Supreme Court even more noticeable how
long is that legal battle going going to
take we don't know we have no idea but
it could be it could be a very very long
time let's see what's on people's minds
about this in super chat and memberships
let me oh okay so people are asking
about the phones I will take calls about
this or anything else but we're looking
for 10 new members patrons or YouTube
channel members so far we have one
someone signed up with the name David
Pakman but it looks like the it's will
Parker will Parker has signed up and I
really appreciate you signing up we'll
thank you very very much and we also
have okay that's it so we're one out of
ten so far if you want to do something
nice for me for my birthday and get a
membership which will get us to open the
phone lines
go to david pakman.com slash membership
and enter the coupon code SAVE 35 I know
that on screen it says vote soon 18
enter the coupon code save 35 on the $60
per year membership select 60 bucks a
year then enter the coupon code save 35
for my birthday we are giving $35
discounts which will drop a yearly
membership to just 25 bucks it's a
really great way to send me a gift for
my birthday maybe you don't care about
that and that's okay but it's a great
way to support the show it'll get the
phone lines opened and it'll be it'll be
a beautiful thing let's see what's on
people's minds about this William
Elmen says my dad Steve Elmen who's the
executive of st. Charles Missouri once
met met Trump and he confirmed that he
indeed has very small hands yeah I saw
an article that argued that Donald
Trump's hand size is being artificially
enhanced via a video photo editing in
some pictures of him I didn't care
enough to actually look into it but I
wonder if that's if that's true but
there's no question the guy had small
hands yeah and I don't know why it
matters but he does vintage Barbie sends
a dollar ninety-nine Super chat with no
question or comment thank you I
appreciate it Harvey with two R's sends
a five dollar super chat should
Democrats just give Trump a photoshopped
image of a large wall and say it's
already built that's I I get that that's
a joke
I actually suggested during the recent
shutdown that if Republicans and
Democrats really wanted to get
government reopened just go to Trump and
say we have a bill that will give you
five billion for the wall he's not going
to read it he doesn't read anything the
presidential daily briefings have been
cut down to a single page a bunch of
images and two and three bullet points
he probably would have signed it and of
course later there there would be
repercussions but that that's an idea
that I mentioned as a possibility
Seifer sends a five-dollar super chat
they can declare a national emergency
for the wall that opens the door for
Democrats to do the same for client
and healthcare yet that's that's an
argument that's being made by a lot of
people on the left which is okay if the
Trump administration feels that they can
make the legal case for undocumented
immigration being a crisis worthy of a
national emergency such that they can
just commandeer money without going
through the normal appropriations
process in in the House of
Representatives next time there's a
Democratic president they can say listen
here's the number of medical medical
expense related bankruptcies here's the
number of people that are spending over
30% of their yearly income on medical
expenses here's what things cost
compared to other countries this is a
national emergency and we're
commandeering the money to put in place
Medicare for all or a medicare-for-all
opt-in or something like that it's a
risky move it's a risky move and I think
you know if I'm on the left I still
fight this now because whether or not
even if Trump is successful in doing
this
that doesn't mean Republicans are just
going to say if a future Democratic
president tries to do health care for a
medicare-for-all via national emergency
it's not like if we let them have this
Republicans will stand by in seven years
when a president says I'm declaring a
national emergency and putting in place
help a Medicare for all they're not
going to do it either way so in that
same sense there's no upside to the left
for laying down here and we also just
don't forget that a lot of this hijinks
is probably related to the fact that the
news in terms of criminal investigations
into Trump wrongdoing
I mean we're learning this weekend
there's going to be an interview on 60
minutes with former acting FBI director
Andrew McCabe where he will say there
was a serious conversation about having
rod Rosenstein wear a wire when he talks
to the president there was a serious
conversation at the Justice Department
about whether we should try to rally the
cabinet into removing Trump from the
presidency via the 25th amendment
these are disasters for any president to
have to contend with and we can't
understate the desire to distract
from every other disaster that is going
on here okay Terry James sends a five
dollar super chat
should we give some form of reparations
for black Americans maybe tax cuts for
black owned businesses
listen I don't have any problem in
principle with reparations I think if
the idea is black owned businesses get
tax cuts what what is what exactly does
that mean what exactly you're suggesting
for how long how many generations who
funds the tax cuts are they funded
equally by all races or only by white
people as soon as you start doing this
stuff I think that you raise a lot of
problematic questions and I think that
there are far less controversial means
to help people who most need help as a
result of historic oppression and
discrimination that I might look at
first that would be way cleaner and I've
talked about some of those on the show
let's see Tyler Fraga has signed up for
a membership at david pakman.com slash
membership that's 2 out of 10 ok so you
can see at the bottom of the screen the
phone lines will open this evening or
afternoon depending on where you are
once we get 10 new members YouTube
channel memberships count website
memberships at david pakman.com slash
membership count you can use the coupon
code save 35 to get a $60 membership for
just 25 bucks I encourage you to do that
and new patrons at patreon.com slash
david pakman show also count we're 2 out
of 10 okay we're 20% of the way there
and I will I'm not afraid to do it I
will open the phone lines if we get to
10 biz Wiz is declaring a national
emergency really just the swipe of a pen
for the president can Congress do
anything can Democrats take action to
push back this just broke so what's
going on now biz Wiz is the legal
scholars and lawyers representing the
Democratic Party are looking at what
challenges are available what mechanisms
for challenge are available the ideal
one would be that the
administration would have to prove in
court that there is a crisis of
immigration worthy of declaring a
national emergency and commandeering
money in a way that's outside the normal
appropriations system if that's the case
the Trump administration will have to
show their work in court to say there's
a national emergency I believe that that
would be very difficult to do we don't
yet know the full scope of what
mechanisms are available to Democrats at
this point in time but we will probably
by tomorrow
ninh Jack's ex sends a $9 99 cent super
chat so Dave here we are two years in my
first super chat to you was about Trump
being a Russian puppet you reserve
judgment do you still reserve judgment
sir no I think at this point it's pretty
clear that Donald Trump is manipulated
and influenced by Russians to say
Russian oligarchs or the Russian
government or whatever we could do in
all of the above probably I don't know
that he I don't think Trump is an agent
of Russia I don't think there's been any
evidence presented of that I think that
the guy is more if anything a de facto
Russian asset he's been entangled with
Russians for so long I don't believe
that there is any reason to think that
there was anything special about Trump
as someone that Russians were trying to
be in cahoots with thirty years ago he
was one of many Western businessmen that
they thought it would be useful to start
being entangled with and as that grew
over time and as Donald Trump became a
viable contender for the presidency it
was sort of the perfect storm and I
think that there a lot of what went down
went down not without Trump's knowledge
but without Trump's necessarily a kind
of evil complicity it would be the way
it went on because the guys [ __ ] more
than anything else and he was just in
too deep
with Russians bomber Fox sends a
five-dollar super chap do you still
think the institutions will hold against
Trump
do you think should be done if they
don't I don't know which institutions
you mean I mean Trump is in control of a
lot of the institutions that are
significant to the United States of
America right now so I don't know what
you mean if they will hold do you do you
mean will democracy hold will voting
systems hold will free and independent
press hold I think they probably will
because Trump's limited to at most
another six years in total but that
would be despite his best intentions
Daniel Cosme sends a five-dollar super
chat David what do you think of a luxury
or commodity tax Kyle kolinsky from
secular talk was talking about it and
outrageously expensive cars that people
buy yeah you can I mean listen we have
this already it's not really that big of
a deal so let me give you an example of
something that's a sort of de facto
luxury tax and by the way thank you to
Lance
Smith who is today's third new member of
the day seven to go and I will open up
the phone lines for people there is a in
taxation there's something called the
mortgage interest deduction what this
means is that if you have a mortgage on
a house you might pay a few thousand
dollars a year in interest on that
mortgage when you make a mortgage
payment part of the money goes to
principle pays down what you owe part of
the money is interest which is the cost
of the loan that's how the bank makes
money when you get a mortgage that is
for less than seven hundred and fifty
thousand dollars you can deduct all of
the mortgage interest that you pay if
you have a five hundred thousand dollar
mortgage and you pay fifteen thousand
dollars in interest that entire fifteen
thousand dollars is tax-deductible it
lowers the amount of income you pay tax
on if you have a mortgage for more than
seven hundred and fifty thousand dollars
you are limited in how much interest you
can deduct I believe the way it works is
you can only deduct interest on the
proportion of the mortgage that is under
three quarters of a million dollars
that's a sort of luxury tax if you have
a mortgage for a million dollars on a
two million dollar home for example you
are in a position of privilege by merely
being able to afford such a home and
thus you can't deduct all of the
interest that you pay you could do the
same thing with a car right you could
say that there is some limits some tax
you could do it a lot of different ways
on cars over a certain amount and as the
car depreciates over time then you know
that would that would phase out
potentially yeah there's a lot of ways
to do that and aren't I think that there
are some mechanisms like that on very
expensive yachts aren't there maybe I
think that's why a lot of people
register their yachts in other countries
I know a couple people who have yachts
and everybody I know says I pay more by
having it registered in the US but I
don't care because it's the right thing
to do it just doesn't seem right to say
this is a Bahamian yacht even though I'm
American and I work in the US that
doesn't really make sense so yeah that's
it that's an interesting idea
welcome to who is the new member welcome
to Justin Levin s Justin Levine s is
today's fourth new member of the evening
four out of ten as the graphic at the
bottom says when we get to ten new
members I will open up the phone lines
people can call in we had a lot of good
callers last night and I would love to
open up the phone lines again we are 40%
of the way there six more members
patrons or YouTube members and I will
get those phone lines opened up generic
name says Ken will bar impede the Moller
investigation at this point I may be
naive but I think that it's too late for
bar to impede the investigation
I think his move would be to limit the
release of the results the findings of
the investigation he was a little bit
squirrelly during his confirmation
hearings about that and that seems more
likely to me than impeding the
investigation itself although the
investigation goes very long still and
it may well do that you may start seeing
pressure on bar to get in the way of the
investigation environmental coffeehouse
says with a nine dollar 99-cent super
Chad if this national emergency does get
declared and the White House says it's
getting declared it opens the door for a
climate mobilization and will backfire
on the orange man this is so critical to
our survival yeah there was a similar
super chat earlier the the thing about
Republicans doing this now or Trump
doing this now opening the door for a
Democrat to do it with health care or
the climate is that number one either
way whatever legal mechanisms are
available to get in the way
like whatever Democrats can do now to
get in the way of Trump doing this for
the wall Republicans will be able to do
later to get in the way of something for
the environment and they will no matter
what Democrats do right now so if
anybody thinks oh if Democrats just let
Trump do this now then Republicans won't
get in the way when future Democratic
presidents try to use a national
emergency for climate action they're
gonna get in the way no matter what so
you may be right but I don't think it's
going to make a difference in the end to
how it works out if the courts will have
to decide the courts are going to have
to decide either way you're not going to
see either parties say to the other we
did it now you get to do it it never
works that way in American politics
Deakin UCLA says with a $10 Super chat
the biggest of the evening I've been
liking Pete Budaj edge for president
what do you think of him and any plans
on doing an interview with him would
love to interview him I don't know if
we've reached out to him yet but I gave
a producer Pat very specific
instructions to reach out to every 20/20
candidate I like him I don't know and I
like his style
and I'm aware of some of his policies I
don't know enough about how he differs
from the other candidates to say much
more than that but I hope to interview
him on the program and think he's a
really interesting candidate Valerie
waters sends me a dollar 99 and says I'm
donating the other $58 to the wall happy
birthday okay I mean if you're a wall
builder I don't know why you would
donate anything to me given that this
program is espousing very different
views but you feel like giving me two
bucks then Thanks
kind of a kind of a weird thing Cerreta
Achmed Yehia says sanctions on Venezuela
actually started in 2017 and they're all
like about medications and essential
materials like medicine vegetable oil
sugar flour yeah yeah we've covered that
so for people who have said that the
reason for Venezuela's economic problems
is decades-old American sanctions on
Venezuela yeah we put it up on the
screen the list of sanctions and as you
point out they started very very
recently and so anyone saying that
problems in Venezuela from 2010 are
because of American sanctions you can
make a lot of other arguments but that
one just is not borne out by the history
books fool in the rain one of my
favorite Led Zeppelin songs asks do you
think that these kinds of Trump tactics
will be adopted by future Republican
politicians absolutely Donald Trump has
set new standards and bystanders I don't
mean high I mean low low bars about what
is acceptable in terms of discourse in
terms of the corseting of political
dialogue in terms of what a president
what a presidential candidate can get
away with and still become president
absolutely and and I've been saying for
a while eventually Trump will be gone
some of what he does can be undone
relatively easily other things camp so
the damage that's done to the climate
every day that Trump doesn't do
something about it to fix the problem
that's much more difficult to undo than
some of the other sort of meaningless
and symbolic executive orders but yes
the one of the biggest problems with
Trump is how he will embolden future
Republicans to be just as bad or even
worse okay vintage Barbie how condemns
take the White House back to words voter
turnout that's it I talked about this
yesterday on the show with Bill share
I've been talking about this for a long
time half the country doesn't vote yes I
want the most progressive possible
candidate I will support
most progressive possible candidate
during the 2020 primary but in the end I
have to do the same thing everybody else
has to do which is just go and vote
that's that's the path forward there's
really no other no other answer Terry
James says don't modern conservatives
essentially believe that the progress of
the past hundred years was good but now
we've gone too far oh I don't know what
you mean by modern conservatives I think
moderate conservatives believe that a
lot of the progress of the human race
over the last fifty to a hundred years
is good but that some things aren't
there is the sort of 1950s conservatism
which which really does seem to be
retrograde in more ways than than you
might be giving credit for and they
fantasize with going back to it's not
it's not even about conserving at this
point what they they want to conserve
something we're way beyond so it's
really going backwards it's the it's
regressing it's the opposite of progress
okay I've got another new member to
thank Antoinette ward
Antoinette Ward that is five new members
during today's stream if people want me
to open the phone lines I will do it but
we just need five more members and
membership is really cheap membership is
the primary way we fund the show
membership gives you access to an extra
show every single day called the bonus
show but more importantly six bucks a
month sixty for the year this is pennies
pennies for every program that we put
together and if you apply the coupon
code save 35 to the sixty dollar a year
membership so on our website you go to
the membership page you switch to the
yearly tab you hit the signup button and
then on page two where it says coupon
code type in save thirty five SAV e35
that's it
and that'll drop a $60 membership to
only twenty five bucks
there are 1,400 people watching right
now if just one percent of you 14 people
take advantage of this membership
special or not just pay the
full-rate if it's affordable we will be
taking live calls before you know it and
that's as we know that's fun for
everybody
Carlos Santana a great guitarist glad to
have him on the stream if the Dems do a
legal challenge on the national
emergency would that put the wall on
hold until it goes through the court or
can trump start construction whenever we
don't know the answer and it's possible
while I've been streaming and talking
about what's going on that we have some
clarity on that that is the question
Democrats are looking at every legal
challenge possible hopefully one that
would prevent any wall building based on
commandeered emergency funds to start
until and if only if the Trump
administration can prove in a court that
there is actually a crisis and not just
a mild crisis but a crisis so
significant that declaring a national
emergency is justified and we don't know
what the answer is to that hopefully we
will we will learn about that soon ninh
Jack's ex says so Dave I haven't heard
any independence like yourself mentioned
Marianne Williamson have you heard of
her have you mentioned her what do you
think of her
not only have I heard of Marianne
Williamson I have interviewed her on the
program I mentioned her once and she is
a pseudoscience whoo person and I'm just
not into that let me see if I can pull
up some info about her but no I'm not
into pseudoscience at all so she is not
someone that I would be able to support
let me see if I can pull up a little bit
of information here and we can look at
it together but where is the information
I am looking for maybe a I think there's
a rationale wiki Marianne Williamson
let's see if I can find that no I can't
okay
in any case I consider her basically
like a BS artist i I mean she's just
it's not for me it's not for me but if
other people like her by all means have
at it biz Wiz there are many random
websites telling people which political
philosophy they aligned with via a test
I've tried a few and have had varying
results should people be trusting this
what these websites I'm not so sure I
would be very skeptical of a lot of
those websites I did my
i side with quiz and the quiz for
example said I was very aligned with
kirsten gillibrand on the basis of
socialism and of course I'm not a
socialist and she's not a socialist so
I'm a little bit scared about some of
these websites giving people just wrong
information about what their own
politics are so I love those in that it
would be great if people were matched
with candidates based on their actual
political views I think that's great it
would separate us a little bit from just
choosing someone who you think has a
good personality or whatever you answer
questions about your political views and
then it says here are the candidates you
most align with my results from the I
side with tests were weird so I would be
a little bit hesitant to say that's a
great way to figure out who it is that
that you that you should support but a
good that you're skeptical about it
because clearly you should be Jackson
says would you consider debating Kyle
kolinsky on Russian interference he
largely thinks it's nonsense also Budaj
edge is not a progressive look at his
tweets about Medicare for all very
reluctant sad I will look into that i I
mean debating Kyle kolinsky on Russian
interference it would mostly I think be
a debate over how important we think the
issue is I don't know what he says about
it because I don't watch anything I
don't know what anybody says on their
shows but it's hard for me to imagine
that Kyle would deny like that we would
have disagreements as to what the facts
are like the Trump Tower meeting
indictments whatever we might disagree
about what level of focus there should
be from Democrats on it maybe I don't
even know I'd have to know more about
his position to know if there's even a
debate in there
Cerreta Achmed Yehia says would you be
mad if I said Lars Ulrich is the best
drummer in the world I wouldn't be mad I
would assume you don't know that many
drummers probably but no I wouldn't be
mad and he's not bad drummer just to say
he's the best in the world seems a
little bit a little bit far-fetched
Michael punt can you add audio from
these live streams into the members only
podcast feed you know that's an
interesting idea
I don't know if we can but I like it I
like that idea why not right let me uh
let me make a note I'm gonna try listen
this is why you should be signing up for
membership on our website they have
asked Michael pond has asked and I am
going to try to make things happen
talk to Pat I'm just making a note about
live stream audio - man it's right it's
hard to write sentences with a sharpie -
member feed yes and as Michael Pond is
pointing out members have their own feed
members get the entire daily show
instead of these clips that we publish
every 90 minutes on YouTube when we do a
new show around 4:00 p.m. Eastern Time
you've got an hour video that is the
entire show for that day no waiting
around for clips so please sign up
please sign up folks that's me doing my
Jeb Bush please clap we're halfway to me
opening the phone lines if people want
to open the phone lines let's get five
more members at david pakman.com slash
membership the coupon code this is 20 20
will save you 40% that will make a $6 a
month membership three dollars and 60
cents if you don't think that the entire
body of work that we do is worth three
dollars a month then that's sad but then
what are you doing here come on
let's let's make it happen okay pumpkin
says what do you think of the idea of
mega Kota I have no idea what that is is
it anti-semitic why am I worried it's
anti-semitic mega Kota oh no it's not
it's merging North and South Dakota into
mega Kota I mean that's just unification
of the the Dakotas sort of like
unification of the Koreas I don't have a
strong position about it I don't know
why I don't know why it's being
advocated or why it's something that
that I should want but I'll look into it
gormer roth says if Trump uses majority
or all of the emergency funds for the
wall what are the consequences if we
have another epic natural disaster
emerge
see likely due to climate change that's
exactly why this is so problematic
because either he's pulling funds
designated for actual emergencies or he
figures out a way to get funds from the
military is another question mark
possibility that I read it's all
problematic and I don't think he has an
answer and judging from the response to
the puerto rican hurricanes it doesn't
really seem to be a high priority for
trump to be perfectly honest Slap Chop
57 says do you think Rosenstein whoa do
you think Rosenstein wore a wire I don't
know I don't know that's a good that's a
good question
we now have heard from Andrew McCabe
that it was seriously discussed we've
never heard a flat-out denial that had
happened and I wonder if it did
hopefully someday we know art Flores
says who is more loyal supporters David
or Trump are you asking who has a higher
number of lawyers loyal supporters or
whose supporters are more loyal
listen 60 million people voted for Trump
so I think that he definitely has a
higher number of loyal supporters are
they more loyal to Trump or to me I
would also say a lot of them are loyal
to Trump I don't have a cult of
personality around me the way that
Donald Trump does for better or worse
Nick angelos sends a $5 Super chat this
is funding for a golf simulator for the
studio yeah that was our 4:30 Eastern
Time clip today Donald Trump installing
the the golf simulator that they had at
the White House that was in there from
President Obama wasn't good enough for
Trump so he installed a new one I can
tell you today Nick I will not install a
golf simulator at the studio Jackson
says speaking of I side with it says
yang supports overthrowing Assad and the
TPP their sources merely that Democrats
support those things I'm skeptical that
he does yeah that it's I think I side
with is a real problem it's a real
problem
James Buchi no says David your thoughts
on Neal Pierce as a drummer did I
pronounce that right I used to always
say Neil Peart and then someone told me
David come on it's Neil Pierce I love
Neil Pierce and I love
everything that he does I love rush rush
is awesome
I think rush is a hugely underrated band
and Neil Peart is fantastic let me say
thank you to psy Hargis who is the sixth
out of 10 new members during today's
livestream six out of ten very very
exciting and shaloom has just signed up
as a YouTube channel member which is 7
so 7 out of 10 3 more new members
YouTube members or patrons and the phone
lines will be open and I look forward to
hearing from people awesome gaming why
do insurance companies deny life-saving
drugs like yesterday they won't cover my
new diabetic meter well listen I don't
know anything about your particular
circumstances so I couldn't tell you why
your insurance company denied you that
and I'm sorry that they did but listen I
mean you know the macro of this health
insurance industrial complex and the
amount of power that is relegated de
facto to employers and for-profit
insurance companies to make decisions
about people's health is immoral and it
should be it should be ended immediately
and I've been advocating for that for a
very very long time let me say thanks to
Kevin Wallace Kevin is today's 8th new
member the target it's a very modest
target we're looking for 10 new members
during the stream and then the phone
lines will open we are eight tenths of
the way there or 80% is another way to
say Kevin Wallace is number eight and if
we get two more new members we will open
up the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
I am very very close very close to
opening up the phone lines let's see if
I can even show you what's going on here
no I really can't I was gonna show you
my phone interface but I won't there's
really no way good way to show it to you
Melanie Bricker says well I think
Melanie's also a member if I recall
correctly Melanie Bricker says what do
you think about beta or work running for
president I hope you're asking me what
do I think
about the possibility that he will run
right he didn't debate Oh announced and
I missed it let me just double check
just so I make sure I know what I'm
talking about beta or Roark um he met
with Chuck Schumer to talk about running
but he hasn't announced yet okay the pot
what do I think about the possibility of
him running
I like beta or Roark although I think
I'm to his left and I am concerned about
running someone whose most recent
achievement politically was losing I
mean okay he did really well in Texas
against an incumbent senator but I don't
know the answer I'm not asking
rhetorically I'm genuinely asking how
should we interpret the idea of running
someone who lost the last attempt to win
something okay Stephen Brent and will
reigns have both signed up for
memberships at david pakman.com slash
membership thank you thank you thank you
really appreciate you guys so I'm going
to go ahead and open the phone lines and
we can I stick to my word I am
completely up front with people if I say
I will open the phone lines I open the
phone lines keep the signups coming at
david pakman.com slash membership you
can now call in at six one seven eight
three zero
4750 no speaker phone no bluetooth
please just your regular phone or a
plug-in
set of headphones nothing else otherwise
everybody gets very very upset I will go
to the phone lines momentarily people
can start queuing up and I see that
people already are I think I had a
couple of other super chats here as
people Colin Jackson says PS a new rules
for dem debates 1% in polls and 60 K
donors Andrew yang is already at 1%
let's get him to 60 K donors yang 20/20
you know Jackson I didn't is that
official or is that an idea I haven't
seen that the DNC put out those
requirements but that's uh that's very
interesting I would be interested in
finding out more more about that okay
let me get set up here to take phone
calls
the best way for me to do this alright I
think we're ready six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty we are
taking phone calls we are going first to
the caller from the six four seven area
code six four seven what's on your mind
hi David this is Sebastian from Canada
hey Sebastian um I have to confess I'm
going to speaker phone but that's
because my face always turns the phone
off I hope that's alright okay we're
gonna try to deal with it your level is
very very low but speak up I know that
you don't generally watch anything on
YouTube but if you saw Andrew yang on
the Joe Rogan show was just completely
blanked on foreign policy I didn't see
that no like what what happened like
what question was he blank on well Joe
Rogan asked him what he would do about
Russia meddling in the American election
and he just said I would issue them an
ultimatum and if they violated it I
would come down really hard on them and
I just think like what does that even
mean no dear that's not right I mean I'm
going by what you're saying but that
doesn't sound great yeah but you know
think you are in touch with him I like
yeah you know I've said that right now
that's of the people that are running
whose platforms I've reviewed in detail
Elizabeth Warren and Andrea anger at the
top of my list and it sort of occurred
to me like maybe I should try to get
involved with it with the yang campaign
if he would be interested at this early
stage sort of informally like maybe just
I don't you know I don't know who am i
right I don't know if he needs my help
and I know he's doing great and he's
getting a whole bunch of press and stuff
but I do think I'd be able to work with
him to really kind of like firm up and
be ready for some of the questions he's
going to be asked but maybe he would
consider my offer offensive you know I
don't know right okay I also had one
more question did you see that there's
going to be a snap election in Spain and
I know you follow Spanish politics I
didn't see that
I really don't follow Spanish politics
that closely my stepmom is from Spain
but from a region that's not embroiled
in controversy so I am not aware of
what's going on but I will check it out
all right thank you Michael okay great
great to hear from you I'll take another
call in a moment Jackson adds these are
the official rules according to yang he
is 15 thousand donors glad he went on
Rogan he's getting more and more support
amazing Rock Lee says please cover the
gorge gage story hashtag innocent
hashtag never Kamala okay I'll check
that out let's go to our caller from the
5:09 area code
who's 509 yeah David this is Blake uh
this is actually my area code is Eastern
Washington but I'm Portland Oregon oh
all right acceptable we've actually had
some disagreements about maduro on
Facebook or on YouTube on some of your
videos but I just wanted to actually
talk about this this possibility of
Trump declaring a national emergency
it's just kind of a general state of our
nation the first thing I thought when I
saw the title of this live stream and
and looked up the article today about
how they're openly admitting that
they're willing to pursue that what when
when does it become time for the
American people to be the American
people you know be We the People take
the rights into our own hands so to say
couple of years ago probably I mean I
think the time for that yeah I'm just
long been going on yeah I absolutely
agree with that but obviously that
hasn't happened right and and and it
just seems like especially with the
election of Trump and everything that's
happened in his his presidency thus far
I mean I just wind when do we say enough
is enough and hey I feel that we do it
means the civil war yeah you know what I
don't want it to but what if it does you
know Trump has said well no I mean we're
going to have an election before we have
a civil war and yeah absolutely
Trump's followers are by and large not
going to abandon him and we talked to a
cognitive neuroscientist today this week
on the program about why we know from
the writing of people like Jonathan
about why it's I mean it's not gonna
happen okay so this is going to have to
happen without Trump's followers and
that just means people have to vote and
I know you know bill scher was sort of
not
he said well listen everyone I brought
this up he said everybody thinks or
wants to have the trick to increase
turnout so that you went on turnout
usually people aren't are able to do it
so then the question is what how do you
get people to actually go and vote but
it's just about getting people to vote
who don't normally vote by getting them
to understand the gravity of the
situation absolutely yeah and I I agree
it it really is such a small minority of
people that think the way the Trump
doesn't buy into what he believes but
they are vocal and they get their
message out there even people who maybe
aren't quite as gone I would say as they
are and it's just it's causing a lot of
problems and it's causing a lot of pain
and suffering and I just I feel like
it's hard to know what the answer is and
when we need to actually take action
beyond what we normally do with
elections and voting I think the time is
now I think the time is now and I'm
gonna do everything I can to to get
people to take that action I appreciate
the call great to hear from you James
Buchi know says if he a super chat if
Alana Mar theoretically ran in 2020
would you think about voting for her at
all or is she automatically a no vote -
you know no one's automatically a no
vote but there were already other people
running in 2020 who I would choose over
her both Elizabeth Warren and Andrew
yang so if she ran in 2020 she would
already not be first on my list so yeah
that's that let me say thank you to Beth
Leslie and Evelyn O'Hara thank you to
both of you signing up as new members at
david pakman.com slash membership let's
go next - what area code looks good
what's an area code 3 phase 3 for 7 I
think might be Massachusetts who's 3 for
7 hello that's you yeah hi um uh it's
actually New York but I'm currently in
Massachusetts so well yeah yeah yeah
Michael Moore recently said that
if they could lower the age to run for
president to 30 that Ocasio cortez would
make a great candidate and I know that's
something that's very unlikely to happen
but I was wondering would you support
something like that do you think she's a
viable candidate somebody who could kind
of push this progressive agenda that's
really kind of sweeping the Democratic
Party well on personality and
unenthusiastically boating and there
could actually be like a turnout case to
be made for her I think she is I think
she would struggle in any kind of debate
setting I think that that would be a
challenge and I think that she still
lacks a lot of basic knowledge about
many issues that would have to be dealt
with in a candidacy for president but a
few years down the line I think that
that could change as she becomes more
experienced but right now if she ran in
2020 I think that she would be severely
outmatched in terms of experience by
people who are not super to her right
and thus she probably would not end up
doing that well on a debate stage with a
lot of the other people already running
yeah I I do agree with you um and I do
think this kind of progressive sweep is
kind of gonna meet its match with Donald
Trump I know he made a lot of comments
about socialists and stuff instead of
the Union do you think that's gonna be a
hard sell for a lot of voters it is
which part going to be a hard sell uh
just kind of the progressives like
Medicare for all increased tax rates
it's something that you know like you
talk about a lot of candidates have
bought into yet like Kamala Harris and
Cory Booker I'm wondering if you think
that's gonna really take hold and kind
of reach al-ahli super-delegates that
somebody like Bernie Sanders would need
the super-delegates are less relevant in
2020 than they were in 2016 because of
some changes that were made so I think
it's less about that and more about who
inspires people to actually get out and
vote because particularly in early
Democratic primaries the turnout is low
enough that one candidate mobilizing an
additional
thousand people can get them in a
significantly better position so I think
it's more about that than appealing the
super-delegates at least at the early
stage yeah all right well thanks so much
okay yep thanks for the call great to
hear from you let's try the 978 area
code caller from 978 what's your name
where you calling from
[Music]
yes it is and I'm hearing music and it
sounds like you're on speakerphone okay
well okay let me fix that my apologies I
was like my name is pyretic my name is
my name is Freddy I'm from the Lawrence
area and you get to sort of give you a
bit of a story I got myself into a bit
of a political debate with several of my
friends a couple weeks ago we were
talking about certain issues like the
wage gap euthanasia abortions etc and to
make a bit of a long story short I made
a bit of a fool of myself as I wasn't
able to assert my ideas in a
constructive manner and I was wondering
if you have any sort of tips on how to
engage in a political debate with anyone
without getting into a dispute or even
causing a physical or verbal altercation
wait it's so okay there so you mentioned
two things you said you weren't able to
express yourself the way you would have
liked or in a productive manner but then
you mentioned ethical and an altercation
was there a physical altercation uh no
there was a verbal altercation okay and
what would happen people started yelling
over each other people start people just
started yelling I don't really want to
go into a lot of details about it okay
we're the were the were the people that
were yelling were they yelling insults
or were they yelling arguments about PA
they're yelling install they were
calling me they were calling names and
yeah pretty much yeah
pretty much it wasn't pretty well
usually when that happens it's not just
one person's doing so it's usually
unlikely that one person would be able
to prevent it but as far as you could do
you know it's good to here's one idea
whenever you are in these conversations
imagine even if it's not true that the
other person isn't saying crazy [ __ ]
because they think you're a bad person
or because they want to hurt people or
whatever but they just don't have all
the information that you have and
imagine that if only they had the right
information they would come to the same
conclusion you would obviously that's
not literally true but the idea is if
you think about it that way it sort of
sets you up to approach the conversation
in a slightly different way and then
sometimes instead of escalating you get
more into questions like how did you
come to that conclusion what would
change your mind what do you think the
people who have a different view than
you are trying to achieve so like that
can be an effective disarming question
imagine that there's a big debate about
taxes for example and you're arguing
with someone who wants no taxes and says
taxes are theft you could say to them
what do you think the people that
disagree with you and that think taxes
on the rich for example should be higher
what why do you think they support that
and a few people would say because they
are just mad at rich people and they
want to steal their money but most
people would say well I think they
probably believe that it's better than
for the economy if that's what we do and
then you can say oh why why might they
think that why might people think that
taxing the rich is better for the
economy and you're starting to get them
in the mindset of someone who shares
your perspective without attacking them
and without necessarily putting them on
the defensive so I think that you know I
don't know that there's necessarily a
specific answer in there but that type
of thing I find to be much more
effective and prevents the the
escalations that you're describing ok
another question I have is I'm a high
school student so I've been noticing as
a recently that there has been a
relative increase in the amount of no
school or high school students that are
vaping or jeweling as they like to refer
to it and I want to know sort of one of
your consensus a consensus on vaping and
how could the state the state or federal
government realistically address the
vaping academic - yeah you know I don't
know what to think about it I haven't
looked at whether so you know vaping the
pitch is that it's vapor and not smoke
and therefore it's not bad or as bad for
your lungs I don't know if that's true
or not and I'm just not really informed
enough to say okay alright the thing
thank you anyways David hope you have a
good evening
thank you appreciate the call great to
hear from you we have dozens of people
holding let's go so hard to pick an area
code let's try seven eight one call her
from the seven eight one area code
what's going on that mean that is you
cool um alright so David would you like
to see a Bruins game with me sometime
this spring I have no idea I don't know
who you are and only if you have front
row seats okay well I usually don't sit
in the front row you know I don't really
go to you know what I'm so annoyed now
with crowds at sporting events and music
concerts that I have almost completely
stopped going unless like I know someone
in the band or that works with the team
and can get like some kind of more
comfortable situation because the crowds
are just such a pain in the ass and like
I'm going to DC in a couple of weeks and
a friend of mine works for the
Washington Wizards and I'm going to go
to my first Basque pro basketball game
in years because I'm just annoyed by the
crowds and the the rush and the racket
and the entire thing I think I'm just
getting old that might be what's going
on yeah I think that's kind of what it
sounds like to me
yep and IIIi can have phones with crowds
at some times but anyway my real
question for you okay is a little bit of
a situation I have to present my father
is probably the most right-wing person I
know I'm sorry you know we live in
outside we live outside Boston can you
hear me oh I can hear you fine yeah yeah
okay okay yeah we live outside Boston
super liberal area but he is like beyond
right-wing just crazy um and my parents
are divorced okay he was pretty abusive
when I was little
through my development years and so
recently I applied for like an Honor
Society in my college yeah and I was
rejected and when I told him about it he
said that it's just the college is
attacking the white man they don't they
don't want white men in the owner
Society bulla bull you know all the
crazy garbage crap and I was telling him
no it was my fault you know I didn't
last semester I didn't work as hard as I
probably should have yeah and I was
trying to kind of get him to kind of
connect with me and talk with me because
he did well in school at his age when he
was younger and I kind of want to learn
from him but he won't accept the fact
that it's my like doing that did it he
will not say it shy away from the idea
that my college is trying to oppress me
because of my whiteness yeah do you
would you how would you handle a
situation like this what could I say to
him to persuade him to see things from a
non delusional point of view I mean
listen here's the difficulty of it and
it's especially difficult with people in
our family friends loved ones it doesn't
sound like he reasoned his way into the
position that he currently has so I
don't know how you can use reason to get
him out of it I I don't know the answer
to that I mean you know if it were true
that like imagine that
99% of the people who did get in are
also white it would sort of invalidate
the idea that you're not in because
you're white right so like if it just so
happened that you had something like
that that you could present maybe that
would get his attention but I don't know
if people who don't use reason to get
into a position are unlikely to be
reasoned out of it
yeah yeah frankly my mother has said
some things very similar about him and
guards to reason but yes so the people
who
hello uh-oh looks like we lost him
all right well listen um we lost you
very sorry to hear about that situation
it sounds it really sounds not not good
we've got a bunch of people from the 5-1
to area code one two three four five I'm
gonna pick up on one of the five one two
people where is five one two that so
many people are calling in from there
hello about me
yeah that's you that's me okay five one
two would be um that's Austin ma'am
Austin Texas okay that explains it that
explains it what's going on yeah yeah um
yeah I was just sort of wondering how
you thought so I'm a I'm a junior in
high school and me and some of my
friends are gonna be able to vote in the
2020 election some of my in the water
I thank you I'm screwing wrong but but
that's true yeah so um a lot of a lot of
Democrats and liberals and stuff talk
like in the people like the the fact
that they're gonna be voting is somehow
gonna help the Pratt's bowels wondering
if you thought it was possible that
there might be a lot of um conservative
young people who vote for the first time
in the next election do you mean a lot
of right-wingers are making there are a
bunch of right-wingers who tweet stuff
that are saying this is the most
conservative new generation of voters in
a very very long time I've not seen any
good data suggesting that all the data
I'm seeing is still that every
successively younger generation is more
to the left on the issues then the older
generations but if someone wants to
present me information that says what
you're saying what you're asking about
which is there's tons of new Young
Conservatives that are going to be 18 19
20 years old at the time of the next
presidential election I'm willing to see
it I just it's not been presented to me
yet yeah I haven't seen any other data
to back it up and either but I will say
that you know there's these conservative
online platforms like Prager you kind of
uh I guess you say the intellectual dark
and stuff like that in I don't I think
you'd be hard-pressed to find a white
teenage male right now who is not
familiar on some level with like people
like Ben Shapiro and Jordan Peterson
that's been my experience it's like very
pervasive level I don't know that
Ben Shapiro and Jordan Peterson have
that high name recognition I mean I know
a lot of people because of my sister who
are between 15 and 20 I would be shocked
if 15% of them knew who Ben Shapiro and
Jordan Peterson were I mean maybe you
know once if you just subselect from the
18 19 and 20 year olds yes that number
would go up but yeah I don't know I'm
not sure about that I have to think
about that I guess it'll just have to
see in the next election yeah yeah
absolutely yeah
yeah I want to get your take on that
okay thank you for the call I appreciate
it
let's see who else do we have here
all right let's see by the way everybody
else from five ones who hung up it seems
like they assumed that was the only
Austin Texas guy getting on I would have
gone to somebody else let's go to a five
one three the five one three area code
is next worse five one three located hey
hey that's you Oh kind of like a third
person said hello in the background that
was weird thinking about this rather
desperate move on Trump's part to get
funding for his wall yep I mean I'm just
kind of wondering what's gonna be the
tipping point to get those fascist asses
the White House I hope that we've
already experienced it and that the guy
is going to lose in 2020 I don't know
like maybe we're past the tipping point
maybe we're not there yet whatever it is
it's not going to be a tipping point
because Trump ists finally realize they
need to abandon Trump the tipping point
is going to be something happens that
gets people to realize they've got to go
out and vote even if they don't normally
vote in 2020 and I don't know if we're
past that tipping point or not I'm
scared that we're not because
I mean listen Trump continues to have an
approval in the high 30s into 40 and you
can win an election with 26% approval
because half the country doesn't vote so
I don't I don't think we're past the
tipping point I don't know that we ever
will know if we are and it's going to
come down to people voting that's it
yeah probably and I was thinking about
you know dimension Trump supporters how
insane the qa9 conspiracy is because
wait a all of the conspiracy theories I
see like involve powerful people and
they're like not trying to cover for
powerful people but queuing on is like
the first conspiracy theory I've seen
that actually tries to protect the most
powerful person in the United States
okay yeah I don't know much about Q and
on but that's I like I really like your
first question I'm gonna let you go
because I've got a lot of people holding
here q and on is not not a big thing for
me okay let's go to the four for three
area code who's there at four for three
hello my name is Court and I'm calling
you from Maryland great what's going on
well David by a longtime listener
first-time caller thank you and I heard
some things that you said about
Venezuela and I appreciate your
commentary on mr. Maduro and your
commentary on mr. Guido however I would
like to ask your opinion of what you
think American involvement in the region
will do to the people of Venezuela given
the history of American involvement in
Central America and South America coming
off the late 19th century where most of
it has been racist exploitation of
resources mainly agricultural resources
that lead the people destitute and poor
and then when they become upset with the
circumstance and try to rise up we end
up with El Salvador Nicaragua or
underwater I think American involvement
will be terrible I think it will only be
negative but I've said that a lot I
don't want the u.s. to get involved and
again as you're pointing out looking at
history tells us that when the u.s. gets
involved in Latin America it's almost
exclusively disastrous III that's that's
my assessment too and I feel like I feel
like the disingenuous argument with
people who say that America
stepping in to I mean I understand
Maduro has a lot of corruption in this
government and this is what I've heard I
don't know if this is true because it
could be so much misinformation but I'm
not gonna defend Maduro because I don't
follow Maduro and I don't know what
actually is going on there but I just
wanted the opinion of someone I know
you're from Argentina and they're just
your opinion I think is a little more
valid okay well thank you yeah I mean
listen I'm against US involvement but I
think Maduro is a disaster I don't I'm
I'm against all authoritarian strongmen
leaders so I'm against Maduro I don't
like uh dawuan
I don't like Bashar al-assad I don't you
don't I I do yeah but you understand
that glide oh not being perfect doesn't
mean Maduro is any better right right
right right I'm not I'm not I'm not
condemning either one okay I've heard
about the corruption in Maduro
government heard about but I don't
follow Venezuelan politics is closed in
American politics yeah yes I mean it's
the fact that it's it's it's not as
corruption it's the authoritarian it's
thinly-veiled populism covering up
extreme authoritarianism and the sort of
taking a part of just the fundamental
institutions of democracy and their
ability to operate it fairly and
independently okay thank you for the
call I'm gonna have to wrap there I'm
out of time I've got a bunch of stuff
I've got to do
to everybody who joined me I will stream
again thanks to all of the new members
thanks to everybody it's really been a
pleasure having you on the stream today